syndicated radio host host of life
liberty and levin
here on fox news channel and the author
of the new book
american marxism number one new york
times bestseller sold 400 000
copies in the first week mark thanks for
being here congratulations
it's a great pleasure thank you my
friend you know we're coming out of this
piece from mike emanuel
we've talked a lot about race
and the efforts in schools to change
how we talk about our history in this
book
you essentially say that's part of a
plan
look here's the thing brad this book has
over 400
endnotes people say to me who are these
marxists
i've got stacks and stacks of books i've
read their stuff
i've read what these professors have
written i read what they teach
i read the national education associates
association the american federation of
teachers
i look back at the history and i'll give
you a perfect example
that is an unbelievably good
journalistic
piece that was just shown and that you
folks at fox have been showing
you dug into this deeply you've done
something nobody else does
okay when you look at the background of
critical race theory this comes out of
critical theory
where does that come from comes from a
school called the franklin school that
comes out of berlin
these are a group of marxists one of the
gentlemen
fled hitler came to the united states he
became a very prominent professor his
name was herbert marcus
he was the founding father basically of
the critical theory
critical theory was the basis for the
new left movement the weather
underground the sds and all the rest
and then you have a gentleman by the
name of derrick bell at harvard law
school first at stanford then at harvard
he takes this idea
which i'll get to quickly and he
racializes it
and thomas all had written about him
over the years and said the guy was a
kook
it's a fringe ideology critical race
theory just to put it in plain english
is basically louis farrakhan dressed up
as scholarship
that's what it is hate america
anti-semitic
anti-white and so we try to put some
kind of historical perspective on it the
perspective
is that anything white is bad because
that's the dominant
culture you dehumanize people you don't
treat them as individuals
it is a marxist ideology brought here
out of berlin because they want this
you have to have classes you need to
have oppressors and oppressed
the idea that this got into our
classrooms and many parents found out
about it because of the pandemic
they're watching their screen they're
watching what their children are being
taught and they're going what in the
world is going on here
that is what's going on kendi and others
who've written these massively popular
books about it they didn't invent this
ideology
this ideology was invented half a
century ago
and the idea that it's in our schools is
unbelievable
i read the book and you make some really
interesting points but
from the other side the pushback would
be
that you're going too far that you're
labeling too many people marxists
and that this is not behind what the
bodine administration
is trying to do when you hear that from
somebody
who wants to give the biden
administration the benefit of the doubt
what do you say
i asked them what have they read i can
cite dozens and dozens of people
i can show you dozens and dozens of
professors tenured in this country
i can show you black lives matter in the
leadership which proudly says that they
are
dr near marxists i can show you
book after book after book after book
after book
one after another after another that are
in our classrooms
that are in the public culture right now
and this is the thing i don't go around
calling everybody marxists i
say that this is an american marxist
various these movements that are taken
from
these various scholars and various uh
various movements many of them in europe
and it's not just critical race theory
well what is it
what is it when you're teaching to
destroy our monuments
to destroy our books to destroy our
history
to push a a racist ideology you talk
about taking down the economic system
people riding in the streets uh
and when people themselves self-identify
as marxists and so forth
what am i supposed to call them the boy
scouts and the girl scouts
all right so listen at the end of the
book you have your own prescriptions
about the way forward
and basically the message is that you
have to
not let this go too far and take back
the country is that fair
yeah my message is that people who love
this country i don't care what color you
are what religion you are
what kind of sex you practice i don't
care let's put some of our differences
aside
and let us take on the people who don't
in legitimate
ways ways that america supports one
institution after another because
they're being devoured the children
in elementary school the borders the
attack on our economic system
uh this degrowth movement dressed up as
climate change
yes and there are many ideas in the back
of the book links groups
uh red-blooded americans who care about
this country it's time to push back
the book is american marxism mark we
appreciate you coming on and congrats
thank you very much god bless